elon musk
is not untouchable this is why i brought
it up in the last podcast saying
elon musk could be the target of the
federal government and twitter because
he's becoming too powerful
they don't like one individual getting
too powerful
if he becomes too powerful through you
said 37
what was the number 37 percent is it
page one yeah 37 percent of americans in
a recent online survey say they've made
trades based on elon musk's tweet
that's out of 30 400 responders they
said yes we responded to his tweets and
we invested in what he did 16
said that invested many time based on
tesla ceo's tweets nearly half of a
respondent said they
found musk's market moving tweets quite
amusing in august 2018 musk
got himself in trouble with the u.s
securities and exchange commission after
tweeting
about taking tesla private said he had
funding secured recently his tweets
about gamestop had drawn
the ira bill gross who made an ill-time
bet against
gamestop and january and caused them to
lose much 15 million
at one point musk is a little devil and
he enjoys playing these games growth
said about him last month so
you know guys like him got to be a
little bit careful but tom
why don't we go into the story that you
want us to go into which is a spacex
story
okay elon musk spacex now owns about a
third of all
activity uh active satellites in the us
uh spacex created a sporm of about a
thousand satellites that is circulating
about 340 miles overhead for some
uh early customers of 99 a month
startling service the satellites
are already moving already improving how
rural communities
access internet more startling
satellites were put in orbit last year
than had been launched by the all the
rocket providers in the world in 2019.
that is
insane spacex has promised that
satellite clusters
will bring cheap high-speed internet to
the masses by beaming data
to every corner on the globe the company
now says it has roughly
10 000 customers which proves that
starlink is no longer theoretical
and expiry mental fiber optics-based
internet providers are
against hit and are pushing back against
the federal government's decision to
award spacex
nearly 900 million dollars in subsidies
tom
thoughts there is always a mission
behind the mission for elon musk
you know i did a case study two years
ago and i said that i thought tesla was
an energy company
and now everybody's coming guess what
you know popular
popular media and press are getting
behind that and i pointed out i said
look
the the infrastructure to charge the
tesla is going to become an industry and
it's valuable unto itself
the power wall and everything they've
done especially when you look at higher
energy cost states like hawaii
here's what i think is happening here
spacex oh he wants to send somebody to
mars oh he wants to make money launching
things for other people
no it's a communications company just
like tesla is an energy company
underneath
i think spacex is a communication
company underneath he wants to
he is passionate about education and he
is passionate about communication
i think that's what's under spacex
that's what i think is going on
telecommunications that's behind the
scenes what's going on here yep
look he's he's building a network he
wants to have free education out there
for
for for the average person he's got a
big heart for the average
you know the average person living in a
rural community to have
connectivity to the internet and the
education background do that that's what
i think is going on
so he's uh here's my question to you as
a business owner and this is the part
that stuck to me obviously it's
ridiculous that one-third of all
satellites in space is 2019.
from elon musk like what um here's my
question to you as a business owner it
says
must noted in a tweet that the company
needs to quote unquote
pass through a deep chasm of negative
cash flow
over the next year or so to make
starling financially viable
from a business owner what does that
mean that you need to spend money in
order to make money what's your take on
that specific sentence it's nothing new
it's it's
that that happens to a lot of people
means i'm a startup and i'm going to
build through it
that's not even a it's a no-brainer he
has to do that it's a normal concept for
where he's at
it's what people had to go through with
them in tesla it's what people had to go
through with amazon and bezos it's what
people had to go through
right that's been around for a while and
here you're not betting on the company
you're betting on
elon to be able to pull this off so
explain that a little bit further when
you say oh it's a common thing and
that's why i kind of set you up for this
what does that mean exactly so when
you're starting a business you
understand that you're going to take
some deep losses you need to invest
and you're going to lose millions or
invest millions in order to come out on
the other side
three to five years later to make 10
million 100 million whatever the number
like
what's that business model i mean how
many times have you seen one of the
rockets he launches
explode how many times have you seen it
now i've seen it a few times how many
times is it
like seriously we've seen it many times
right what's the big deal nowadays
nothing and do you know do you see how
he handles it let me get this straight
you run a company
that you know sends
rockets into space and
failing is what part of the process an
explosion
and he says ah okay all right next one
it's not like
it's the end of the world this guy's got
rockets exploding left and right and
it's just like going off to the next one
because in his mind it's like i'm gonna
figure this thing out
you gotta worry about i want to figure
this thing out my only concern
is go back to a time where one
individual has ad had had as much power
and influence as he does and their name
wasn't
starting with a president tell me the
last time an
individual had more power and influence
more power and influence than elon musk
does today and their name didn't start
with president
tell me what's the rock john d
rockefeller yeah i disagree i fully
disagree with you guys
because he didn't have the power of
twitter guys there is no social media
with rockefeller what are you talking
about rockefeller would write a story it
took you two weeks to read about it
he would send a tweet it took a month to
find out about it
china didn't find out about what
rockefeller said for two months how are
you going to find out about the news
there's no way to send it to you
this guy says something boom like this
people go on
you know short trade e-trade their
website
marcus and they buy stocks and they go
on robin hood
so when we're officially at a phase
where individuals
can have more power than countries and
this guy is getting to a point right now
who has more influence right now for
people to take action
if joe biden tweets tomorrow go buy
walmart stock how many people buy it
maybe like four no everybody's shorts
yeah if ilan was tomorrow if joe biden
says tomorrow hey you know what
uh here's what i think about dogecoin
they were like dude you don't know
who sent us to it like can you we want
to know the staffer
but if but he would call it doggy coin
and he would actually call walmart
kmart so let's remember we're talking
about that's a good point but if this
guy goes out there and sends a tweet
who responds to it the entire world
stops apparently 37
of americans are making trades based on
a elon musk that concern that
we're about to find out how
how you know there was a book written
just
with all of trump's tweets it's a book
you go buy the book
it's all of his tweets in a book and it
was a bestseller it's a book
with his tweets okay and it explains the
timing of the tweets
trump was able to get world's attention
with one platform
okay now some may say this guy's taking
it to a whole different level elon musk
the kind of influence that he's having
right now because if you if you think
about trump's influence wasn't go by
real estate in new york
trump's influence wasn't go by the stock
that wasn't trump's influence trump
wrote a book called what art of the deal
right and they did very well and
bestseller for many many years trump had
a tv show trump was entertaining trump
was making money trump was doing all
that stuff
but trump wasn't telling you where to go
invest your money trump wasn't go trump
played a political game he put a
one-page ad and you know president bush
going to war not the right decision and
he put that i don't know what the
newspaper was in new york times or
wall street journal he put him one of
those he he played for longest time he
was involved in politics
this guy's influencing other industries
so we're about to learn what happens to
an individual who has this much power
and recently he comes out saying
he supports free education but not the
kind of free education of 50 000
to discount it he gives five million
dollars to khan academy a generous five
million dollar donation to khan academy
khan academy i think he started the
website he started his youtube channel
helping his
niece or something do homework it's a
simple story now he supports
free education but not free education as
in scholarships
free education as in you could go to a
youtube channel and take geometry
you can go to this one place and learn
about the history of this you can go to
this one place for free and learn about
coding
he is he is hurting a lot of industries
he is hurting a lot of companies he is
taking business away from a lot of
powerful people
and i'm just wondering at what point is
there going to be a meeting behind
closed doors
of all the people that he's putting to
work there's nothing
more annoying than you're somebody
that's making 10 million every year and
you've been kicking back for 15 years
golfing seven days a week
you're just chilling you go to the
restaurants mr whatever your last name
is and then all of a sudden a guy shows
up where you have to get back to work
and you haven't worked for 20 years
people don't like people like that
behind closed doors those people are
hated i have a bit of an experience in
that myself personally
elon's taking that to a whole different
level he is hated because
he's putting a lot of his competitors
back to work of having to show up to
office early again
because he's not stopping so what how
long will this last
i have no idea i have no idea so it
doesn't sound like you guys have an
opinion on it okay
do you think there's a simulation
between uh reed hastings
and um elon musk in the sense that they
kind of they
disrupted big industries and and
blaze the path uh no
reid hastings is not elon musk reed
hastings is just a guy that
destroyed you know hurt and industry
where how many the grammy awards went to
netflix was it 17 i don't know what it
was the number was just ridiculous
right and where a uh gervais what's his
name ricky gervais he goes up and says
you know forget about who are you guys
you guys are nobody everybody's calling
netflix and he said if
the uh uh what did he say if the isis
was to come out with a new streaming
service you would be calling your agent
to say get me on that streaming service
to get a contract with them right
meaning you're selling your
soul to anybody so no what netflix did
is one industry
he's not doing one industry he is not
touching one industry
he's touching five 15 20 industries
he is going to collectively piss off a
lot of people
and those people that he pisses off
their expertise is to have paid off a
politician in the back
where no one knows about and those
politicians own
oh those people a lot of favors and i
don't know what's going to happen dude
honestly i don't know what angle they're
going to take with them what's really
interesting you bring up something very
interesting i think we have to peel it
back a little bit and take a look both
spacex and tesla have something in
common they have federal subsidies on
their
on their products and so you got the 500
million
correct the spacex that's right spacex
billion dollars isn't a big number from
the government but that's
very very real and so the um the rural
education play and
and the satellite play for rural
internet it's got a billion dollars of
subsidies
meanwhile you got these guys time warner
and people like that verizon putting
fiber
optics in the ground or getting really
pissed off by that and
as we all know there's still you know um
what fifteen thousand dollars of federal
subsidies in every electric vehicle
so you know when you add up the battery
and all the parts and everything that
goes in and actually the end price
and so there's you know there's a lot of
government that is lined up in the u.s
with elon and so the question is does
the lobbying go the other way and have
it shift and that's what i look for i
look for when does elon start to lose
the
support of the government in the form of
these subsidies because he's got some
friends somewhere
um and they're helping us somewhere elon
they're given subsidies from the
government
somebody's somebody's been part of a
meeting that says hey
you know what here you go you know who
are the scariest people i've ever
competed against
you know you know what people i actually
fear when it comes down to competition
the scariest people you'll ever face in
your lifetime
that that could ruin you not willing to
do whatever they can to hurt you
is lazy ambitious people yeah yeah
lazy ambitious people are the most
dangerous people you'll ever go up
against
because they're lazy but they're
ambitious they're not willing to do the
work that you're doing to get the
success you're getting
but they still have your level of
ambition if not higher lazy ambitious
people are great manipulators and game
players
phenomenal added so meaning what
how many people does elon face today who
are lazy ambitious people who were at
one point somebody 20 30 years ago or 15
years ago
who are now ambitious still but very
very lazy how many
that's described most of the auto
industry i just described most of the
auto industry i just described most of
politicians i just described most of the
people that are in the financial
industry i just described a lot of
people
who made their money they just don't
want to get to work his number one
enemy is not the sec it's lazy ambitious
people
the lazy ambitious people are who are
the ones that are going to make his life
a living kill you know what's a crazy
thing about lazy ambitious people
you rarely know they start it but they
know and say oh he did it
that's the secret sauce of lazy
ambitious people i don't know if that
made sense or not
so they go behind closed doors and they
know how to do
did you hear about what that person said
about you oh look i got
i mean let me tell you what i did i
defended you i got a call from a guy
saying hey
the other day was this place and they
said this about you but let me i said
i said first of all why are they so
comfortable to talk smack about me in
front of you the whole line that jade
uses in this song why are they so
comfortable to talk smack about me in
front of you
maybe you gave them that comfort that
they can talk smack about me in front of
you so maybe you joined the club
of let me have them trash or buddy here
so the lazy ambitious people behind
closed doors
they know how to put the thing together
and they say you know what he said about
you
and they're like oh i did it
responsibilities off them so they still
they close allies and they put it on him
but they started the whole thing
he's giving birth to a lot of people
like that working and
uh because okay do you think they're
gonna let this guy be worth
a trillion dollars in the next five
years do you think
that to the point where he says this
okay you don't want to give me the
subsidies of 900 million i don't care i
got 900 million don't give me the
subsidies
i'm worth a trillion dollars then all of
a sudden they're going to say oh [ __ ] he
no longer needs us you know what
boom lock him in people like elon musk
typically the lazy ambitious people get
very scared of people like elon
because ilan doesn't know how to what
how to stop
he's not going to stop he's not trying
to be a billionaire to live in a big-ass
house
that comes with it he's not trying to go
date all the hot girls he's already had
a plenty everybody wants to find out
what this guy's like
he's uh he's not trying to go have
dinner with the cool people he's done it
so many times
he wants to change the world world
changers scare the hell out of lazy
ambitious people
there's not that many people at this
level they're some of the most this
remember how the same way i said lazy
ambitious people are the people
you fear because they know how to behind
closers ruining the game
you know who lazy ambitious people fear
the most ten times more
hard-working ambitious people they're
frightened and envious of elon illama's
type of people
envious because you have that moxie that
they go to sleep every night saying i
actually think this guy's gonna pull it
off and what if he pulls it off and
everybody's gonna realize that i was
wrong and i'm gonna lose face and i'm
gonna do this i can't let that happen
let me see what i'm gonna do they go to
sleep all night long to try to stop that
person
world guess who the world favors by the
way the world
favors guess who history favors
the you're saying not the musk history
favors the bold baby
history history favors the bold and
that's elon musk
history favors the ball that's why we
keep giving birth
to new elon musk so dude more power to
you
go do it just i hope he doesn't get a
little out of control
where he creates enemies that he doesn't
need to create you're gonna create
enemies just don't create the enemies
that are unnecessary enemies to create
speaking of birth of elon musk
do you know how many kids he has five
you knew that yeah
okay do you know the the the breakdown
of the kids i think with the first one
what's four
uh uh was it huh
yeah here's a little fun fact you said
berth he's got
now he has six kids now okay he had he
lost his first kid i believe was his
first never wants to talk about it yeah
he had he has two twin boys yep then he
had
triplets so five boys and now he has a
six boy with the musician grimes that he
named
the kid uh x a some
[Music]
or whatever but do you know one of the
triplets names the youngest triplet or
the
youngest triple cola what is it kai oh
that's cool
kai did you know that you didn't know
how to go
you are you could be the son of elon
musk
could be maybe he is maybe he is we just
don't know about it yeah yeah yeah
maybe he's been planted here to support
anyway i thought that was very
interesting
all boys uh twins
triplets and now a kid from outer space
i like what you just did it's like when
i talk to tikkon dylan sometimes i'm
like guys let me tell you about the
history of what happened here
dad do you know in minecraft how many
different
things you can build we just gotta we
just went to a different direction so
what you you're not worried about it
sounds like you because you think
everything's going to be okay with ilan
no one's going to bother him the lazy
ambitious army is not going to unite and
go on no i i
look there there's a reason here why
we've got you know 10 pages of stories
whatever and
four of the pages are about elon fricken
musk the guy's a financial rock star and
he's
he's otherworldly and even his newborn
baby is named after a
solar system or something so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye